my new national strategy for space
recognizes that space is a war fighting
domain just like the land air and sea we
may even have a space force that was
president Trump speaking to members of
the US Marine Corps and other service
members at an air base in San Diego this
week mr. Trump went on to say he is
considering a so called space force that
would be the equivalent of the Army Air
Force and Navy here to discuss that idea
and its implications is Time magazine
editor at large Jeffrey Kluger good
morning Jeff good morning thanks for
having me space force how feasible is
this there are certain hurdles to
overcome first of all there are
international treaties that limit the
military's militarization of space
the 1967 treaty says that forbids
nuclear or weapons of mass destruction
in low-earth orbit it also forbids all
militarization on the surface of the
Moon or any other celestial bodies so
what does this leave us with you could
have some conventional weapons in
low-earth orbit but shooting down an
enemy shooting down other countries
satellites is an act of war you're
certainly not going to have Star Wars
type dogfights in orbit and ground
surveillance every country in the world
does that Google can do that for
goodness sake so I'm not so sure what
there is to this President Reagan
proposed the Strategic Defense
Initiative in 1983 that's right that
never panned out last year a proposal to
create a new space core military service
was abandoned right what happened
exactly
Secretary of Defense mattis was actually
openly opposed to it he want he did not
want the idea of a space force tucked
into the Air Force in the same way the
Marines are tucked into the Navy
he said it's bureaucratically
complicated we really don't need it it
really can't work Reagan's plan was
defensive it was all about using
defensive weapons in low Earth orbit to
deflect nuclear weapons but the Soviets
at that time said yes but once you do
that you destabilize the nuclear balance
so this abrogates the salt treaty that's
abrogates
the ABM Treaty and we are back off to
the arms races there's also the
practical question of funding all of
this NASA's budget I think is currently
point four percent of the budget back in
the 1960s when we were sort of the
golden age of space exploration it was
4% 4% of the federal budget and that's
the problem Star Wars cost the Reagan
proposal thirty billion dollars over ten
years and never got anywhere if you want
to build the hardware if you want the
ambitious programs that got us from a
standing start in 1961 to the surface of
the Moon in 1969
you have got to allocate the money back
in 1965 in the midst of that program
NASA's budget was the equivalent in 2018
dollars of 60 billion dollars a year
three times what it is now you want to
build the machines allocate the money
Jeffrey I want to talk about your latest
article in time and in which you say
that although President Trump claims
America is going to Mars it's not going
to happen at least any time soon why
it's right well here's the thing with
Mars we are always going to Mars we just
never get there 69 we were supposed to
get there in 75 by this first Bush
administration it was 2019 now President
Obama said we could do it by 2035 Elon
Musk says he could do it by 2024 because
Elon and the fact it is it is a very
hard thing to do and it takes an
enormous amount of money but doesn't
Elon Musk's in sort of a better chair
the wait look he can do these things on
his own and Elon is a force of nature he
may not be from Earth but I think he is
he has the will to do these things he
has if he wants the wherewithal to do it
he does have to show more patience Elon
himself admits that he tends to over
promise he tends to get a little giddy
on his own ideas but he's ambitious and
rich you got to reach you got oats for
the start you know if anyone might do it
Jeffrey Kruger as always a treat to have
you thanks very much for being here
thank you for having me